well there's a tip let's have take a
look at who might be in the running to
replace Teresa may should she lose
tonight's vote of confidence well
amongst the favourites is the man you've
just heard about the former Briggs's
secretary Dominic Robb who resigned over
the draft agreement reached by mrs. May
of course there's always the brexit ear
and former foreign secretary Boris
Johnson he resigned in July over mrs.
Mayer's checkers plan
the Home Secretary Sajid Javid who
backed remain but has since positioned
himself as a lever will almost certainly
put himself forward now the vibrant
secretary and Breakfast dear Michael
Gove who ran against resume in last
year's election just been speaking to
him he didn't rule it out white although
he says he doesn't think it's going to
arise David Davis who resigned as
president secretary in July is seen
perhaps as the elder statesman of the
bricks of Tears
then there's the chair of the European
research group Jacob Riis MOG who's
publicly filed a vote of no-confidence
he's always denied that he wants the job
without quite ruling out running for it
the Foreign Secretary and remainer
Jeremy Hunt has reshaped his position to
support leaving now and he tweeted today
that's saying a leadership contr saying
that a leadership contest is the last
thing the country needs then there's on
the other side the prominent Romania and
Work and Pensions secretary amber Rudd
who tweeted to say that May has her full
support the International Development
Secretary and brexit ear penny mordant
has been the least supported member of
the cabinet so far and don't forget the
leader of the Commons and staunch brexit
ear Andrea led 'some who initially ran
against Mrs May in last year's election
before withdrawing all of course it
could be none of the above
if that's the way conservative
leadership elections go